jetzt ist das letzte buch des
verstorbenen astrophysiker stephen
hawking erschienen und es ist eine
mahnung an die menschheit die wahl von
donald trump der brh exit es handelt
sich um eine revolte gegen expertinnen
und experten und damit auch gegen die
wissenschaft eine messerscharfe analyse
der situation der welt und eine düstere
dazu kriegs und science fiction bei uns
gibt's täglich wissenschafts videos
abonniert den kanal um nichts zu
verpassen
herzlich willkommen können sie mich
hören es war eine wunderbare zeit zu
leben und über theoretische physik zu
forschen unser bild des universums hat
sich in den letzten 50 jahren erheblich
verändert und ich bin glücklich wenn ich
dazu einen kleinen beitrag leisten
konnte
das ist uns menschen die wir selbst
hauptsächlich ansammlungen von partikeln
der natur sind möglich war einem
verständnis der gesetze die uns und das
universum regieren so nah zu kommen ist
ein großer triumph ich möchte meine
aufregung und begeisterung für diese
suche gerne teilen schauen sie also zu
den sternen und nicht kinder auf ihre
füße versuchen sie den sinn dessen zu
ergründen was sie sehen und was unser
universum existieren lässt seien sie
neugierig und wie schwer das leben auch
scheinen mag es gibt doch immer etwas
das sie tun und worin sie erfolgreich
sein können
es kommt darauf an einfach nicht
aufzugeben
danke fürs zuhören das sind laut einer
veröffentlichung der cambridge
university die letzten worte von stephen
hawking ein flammender aufruf an die
menschheit in die zukunft zu schauen und
sie zu gestalten es ist vielleicht sein
wichtigstes vermächtnis denn es ist
nicht nur ein fazit seines lebens
sondern auch ein appell und in seinem
neuen buch brief an source to the
question auf deutsch kurze antworten auf
die große frage unterstreicht er diesen
appell nochmal und er bringt ein großes
problem noch einmal auf den punkt es
sein zitat eine globale revolte gegen
experten und das schließt
wissenschaftler ein so hocking can you
hear me so fangen seine letzten worte
auf englisch an und es waren immer sehr
wichtig gehört zu werden deshalb jetzt
auch noch mal die veröffentlichung des
neuen buches und es ist das buch
experten eines wissenschaftlers und
darin geht es um eine der zentralsten
fragen die sich hawking in seinen
letzten lebensjahren gestellt hat denn
immer mehr trat er in die öffentlichkeit
wohl wissen teil der popkultur zu sein
in star trek spielt er poker mit newton
einstand und data in the big bang theory
verblüfft der sheldon cooper und mit den
monty python singt er den galaxy song
er nutzt seine popularität aber eben
nicht nur für profane unterhaltung
sondern setzte sie immer effektiver ein
um statements warnung und ideen zu
verbreiten ihm war wohl sehr bewusst
welche wirkung der im zeitalter von
facebook twitter und google entfalten
kann und das hatte alles immer öfter
immer weniger mit seinem fachgebiet zu
tun hawking mischt er sich mehr und mehr
in die öffentliche diskussion ein es
dürfte ihm klar gewesen sein wie wenig
zeit er noch hatte und welchen beitrag
er zur gestaltung unserer zukunft
leisten kann wenn hawking etwas sagte
hatte das erhebliches gewicht und so
ging er sehr gezielt themen an die
wahrscheinlich für das fortbestehen der
menschheit entscheidend sein werden
er wirkte als der öffentliche hawking
der weniger über schwarze löcher den
urknall oder die zeit sprach als über
künstliche intelligenz aliens oder das
verlassen der erde
und wenn er in seinen letzten worten die
menschheit auffordert zu den stern zu
schauen dann ist das ganz konkret
gemeint hawkings größte befürchtung war
die zerstörung der erde
denn die kommt laut ihm so oder so egal
ob klimawandel asteroiden super vulkane
und und und die liste ist gar nicht so
kurz hawking sei die einzige möglichkeit
der menschheit zu überleben darin die
erde zu verlassen und damit dürfte er
goldrichtig gelegen haben denn manches
können wir vielleicht abwenden
vielleicht schaffen wir es sogar den
klimawandel abzuwenden oder asteroiden
vor einem einschlag hier abzulenken aber
die summe aller gefahren die ist einfach
nicht abzuwenden seine extremste
vorhersage von 100 jahren in denen wir
spätestens hier aufbrechen ist
vielleicht oder wahrscheinlich sogar
übertrieben aber dennoch liegt er damit
nicht ganz falsch immer mehr entdecken
wir wie wir die erde unbewohnbar machen
artensterben lustig müll überall
überfischung zusätzlich zu den
natürlichen gefahren die drohnen arbeit
die die menschheit sehr effektiv daran
ihren lebensraum zu zerstören es ist nur
weitsichtig uns zu verlassen der erde
aufzufordern und auf anderen planeten
lebensräume zu entwickeln es wird
wahrscheinlich die nächste
evolutionsstufe der menschheit sein
unwirtliche orte so zu verwandeln
dass wir dort überleben können
vielleicht ist die erde gar nicht der
optimale platz um als intelligente
spezies zu überleben vielleicht ist sie
nur unsere wege und dauerhaftere
lebensräume scheinen uns heute als
unbewohnbar haben aber die vorteile dass
sie zum beispiel keinen vulkanismus
haben und keine tektonik an anderer
stelle ist stalking dagegen sogar extrem
technologiefeindlich das ist schon
verblüffend zum einen ist der glühende
anhänger einer sich schnell
entwickelnden raumfahrt andererseits
wieder die menschheit stoppen er warnt
eindringlich vor zwei zentralen
szenarien für unsere zukunft das ist zum
einen die entwicklung der künstlichen
intelligenz zum anderen die forschung
nach aliens bei beidem sind wir schon
sehr weit fortgeschritten und talking
nutzte jede gelegenheit um davor zu
warnen gerade in den letzten jahren ist
eine diskussion über die möglichkeiten
von künstliche intelligenz ki entflammt
und hawking hat sich ziemlich klar
positioniert er sieht die menschheit
durch ki gefährdet er sagt dass es für
uns nicht abzuschätzen ist wie sich uns
gegenüber uns verhält als dann
überlegene spezies passiert das gleiche
wie bei uns menschen beim kontakt mit
weniger entwickelten zivilisation geht
das für die immer schlecht aus wird ki
also die welt erobern und uns vernichten
laut hawking ist das nicht im vorhinein
zu klären und schon jetzt gibt es
beispiele die besorgnis erregend sind
der youtube algorithmus der auf google
brain einer ki basiert ist ein gutes
beispiel erkennt keinen unterschied
zwischen gut und böse oder wahr und
falsch
er hat eine aufgabe bekommen und die
erfüllt er mit bravour koste es was es
wolle er soll die vod stein die
verweildauer auf der plattform
verlängert dafür pusch der videos die
möglichst lange angesehen werden wie
inhalte sind ihm dabei egal dem bereich
wissenschaft führt das dazu dass die
meistgesehenen videos die über
verschwörungstheorien sind videos
in denen erklärt wird warum die erde
flach ist oder warum die sonne kalt ist
das ist zwar noch nicht die ki die uns
als identität gefährlich werden kann
aber dieses verhalten zeigt auf was
passiert wenn wir weniger intelligente
spezies einer ki mit speziellen aber uns
überlegenen fähigkeiten einen auftrag
erteilen die konsequenzen können wir
nicht einschätzen und genauso könnte es
dann auch bei ki mit umfassenden
fähigkeiten seien hawking dazu der
erfolg bei der schaffung einer
effektiven ki könnte das größte ereignis
in der geschichte unserer zivilisation
sein oder das schlimmste wir wissen es
einfach nicht also können wir nicht
wissen ob wir unendlich von der ki
unterstützt oder ignoriert gefüttert
oder möglicherweise zerstört werden und
er hat recht und es ist wichtig dass er
hier seine autorität in die waagschale
legt um uns zum nachdenken und zur
vorsicht zu mahnen und genau so warnt er
auch vor dem kontakt mit aliens denn
hier stehen wir vor genau demselben
problem bzw
derselben frage wie werden sie sich
gegenüber uns verhalten werden sie uns
friedlich begegnen oder uns als er
niedere lebensform wie ungeziefer
betrachten ganz unrecht hätten sie ja
nicht zur zeit sind wir für den planeten
eine plage und eine intelligente spezies
könnte und sogar mit gutem grund von
diesem planeten tilgen und zu vernichten
wäre wahrscheinlich die effektivste
methode den klimawandel aufzuhalten das
wäre den außerirdischen nicht zu
verdenken gut dass es mit stephen
hawking ein gibt der uns diese sicht der
dinge mit seiner autorität näher bringen
vielleicht trägt er damit den einen oder
anderen entscheidungsträger zu mangeln
an die eu jedenfalls plant bereits
regelungen zum umgang mit ki und roboter
ja wenn er diesen text nochmal nachlesen
wollen dann lesen dieses buch hier mit
einem beitrag über den hawking der
letzten jahre der sein ganzes gewicht in
die waagschale eben legte um gehört zu
werden
das ganze gibt es mit eine kurze
geschichte der zeit in diesem schönen
geschenk schuber und ihr bekommt es
direkt einfach hier draufklicken und
hier darunter geht es weiter dafür auch
einfach draufklicken es gibt keine
schwarzen löcher stephen hawking
schmeißt alles um ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran